because you get most of your energy
from breakfast
okay so they're going to start soon
we're going to start in 12 minutes i
only have 12 minutes to finish my cereal
oh
why do i only are using rhinest medium
i'm using cassette dream tape
has a tape dream yeah i'm using
this medium because in the last match
they used animal crossing medium and
then they used the jojo
the giovanni piano bdm
so now i'm going to introduce everyone
to this wonderful bdm
which is called casa dream tape it's an
amazing
medium hopefully it'll calm us down
[Music]
this medium is slap right i've always
wanted to use it
and that's the perfect time to do that
i wonder it's just
it's just.com already streaming i
wouldn't know
because right now we're watching gm
hikaru
it's just welcome already streaming
hello hello hello everybody welcome it
is the second week of tournament arc 2
and i'm here of course with japanese
tutor aka jt what's up dude
much so much uh i was uh
in bed and i was like i have to get up
for tournament like oh my god this is so
crazy let me see
twitter and twitter posted so many
things
and there was also an announcement from
you that i saw on twitter so
i would love to talk about that in a
little bit yeah for sure
and uh we'll definitely get into that we
want to run through some of the basics
of course
for anyone who's just joining us in this
second week uh
about the format of the event and the
prizes who were the participants and
stuff like that
and uh and so let's go ahead and kick
that off we're gonna talk about the
format itself
what is tournament arc 2 how does it go
it is a
double elimination bracket and uh
so we had our first round and then
people were distributed
into either a winner's side or a
redemption side based on
how they uh performed in that first
round
and it's gonna end in a grand final
there's gonna be a winner of the
redemption side a winner of the winner's
side
and then the winner of all winners
in the grand final who will be crowned
the champion of tournament arc 2.
the games themselves are 10 minutes
on each player's clock and they will
also earn 5 seconds
per move so you know if you move really
quickly you can actually gain time on
your clock
they're gonna play a best of three match
so the first player to two points
wins their pairing now if somehow they
end up with one and a half
points each after three games that can
happen a couple ways you could have
three draws or
one person wins the other person wins
and then there's also a draw
they'll go to a tiebreak and we've had
this a few times now where they will
each have
only three minutes on their clock and no
increment uh whatsoever per move which
is uh pretty nuts and uh
so we'll talk about the schedule real
quick this is what we're calling our
week 2 schedule starts today
5 pm pacific our first match will be
rustage versus ali
and that'll be followed by kizzy k
versus techtone
and you see we're missing players on the
23rd and that's because the matches
today
will decide who faces who
uh which is pretty cool
the loser of the ali and wrestling match
will play c doug
and the winner of the techtone kizzyk
match
will play esam so that actually leads me
into what i want to discuss which is
an adjustment that we made to the
bracket
since the end of the first weekend and
it's worth noting that the adjustment
that we made does not affect
the previous results in any way it just
kind of repairs something that was
missing in the bracket and
it's a little tough to explain but
basically the
loser of the w1 match that you see at
the top
ollie versus rustage we'll drop down
into the redemption side
to face cdog va in match r4
uh and the loser of
match w-2 between e sam and gigguk
dropped down into match r3
where you see esam currently placed now
and the reason for that is if the
players
flip over we had it reversed from what i
just described the players actually do
flip
over to face opponents that they were
not originally seated on that side of
their bracket so
what's nice about that is it ensures
that players are much less likely if
they drop down into the redemption
bracket there
to face somebody they've already played
and that's
a really awesome thing so we made sure
that we implemented that just in time
for today
so uh now that we've run through all
that stuff
jt i want to ask you while we still have
this bracket up
how do you feel about today's matches
we've got ollie v rustage
somebody's going to hang on stay in the
winner's bracket and face gig next
and then we've got kizzy v techtone one
of those players will move on to face
esam and the other
one will be absolutely eliminated from
the tournament
so jt your thoughts
i i really want to see what's going to
happen in the
ollie versus vestige match is a zombie
gonna win
is the boy genius rapper gonna win
i don't know it's gonna be crazy toss-up
and then z versus sexton i know both of
them have been working really really
hard on their chests
and going over their games and doing
tactics so
i wonder you know what their experience
in the last
last weekend are they going to take that
and you know prevail
and maybe take the whole thing you can
never
discount somebody's hard work and i'm
sure not gonna do that
yeah absolutely they both have
definitely
been working hard to uh prepare for this
match and we'll ask them a little bit
about that preparation
uh in their post-match interview uh i
also want to mention just before we go
to the break
if you have enjoyed your time watching
chess here on chess.com channels
and you find yourself wanting to see
what
the top level chess looks like you can
tune in
from now through august 6 to
the feed a world cup coverage this is
one of the biggest events
in professional chess and uh we're
streaming almost
every day uh world cup coverage
you see some of the top players there
fabiano caruana
the top player in the us of course
magnus carlson in the middle there the
world champion
aneesh geary also one of the top players
uh
representing the netherlands i believe
and
uh and many more so make sure that you
tune into that coverage it is very early
of course for me
5 a.m pacific so i stay in bed i don't
watch that i'm kidding i do get up and i
watch it it's great
uh we also have some merch
that is pretty awesome i was actually
able to help contribute to the designs
i'm sure you could see some of my style
in there and
there's a discount right now because of
the world cup coverage 10 percent off
you can go
to go.chess.com merch and uh
get some i don't know just chess
life stuff i actually have that hoodie
or it's not a hoodie it's a
whatever it's a long sleeve something
but me it's it's comfy
i wore it in vegas did you see it
it was it was cool it was cool i had a
lot of people ask me about it
so there's that which is nice maybe they
just thought it was an original
because it's your style yeah yeah sure
we'll go with that no i'm actually
really proud of those designs
i think you guys will enjoy them so go
check it out uh but we're gonna go to
break right now because when we come
back
game one of wrestage versus ali
uh obviously lots of fans in the chat
for both players
maybe we'll see some of those emotes
during the break and we'll be right back
in just a few moments so stay tuned
good luck to dr i'm going to save all of
these good looks from you guys
and put it in my pocket oh
it's about time i turn off the live chat
see you guys uh yeah a bit
the dressage stream crashed
research stream crashed
yeah bye
be taking them thank you very much
smiley
i'll do my best
oh okay uh he's good now it seems
leave in your pod armor i will well i'm
going to turn off the live chat now i'm
going to miss you guys
see you later after the uh
after the first round is over love you
guys
okay and now the chat is officially off
good luck queen thank you good morning
holly good morning good morning
hope you guys had a nice sleep i can't
go into right right
i'm
wait what do we do
wait
okay i opened live chess
perfect gaming coming to stand by okay
we're going to start soon
good luck to the both of you
that's a that's a doorbell
help it yep
so nervous
one minute to the games
good luck you've got this thank you keep
focusing don't trust
right it's a 10 minutes game
you just gotta keep calm
take your time look at the board
and we should be starting soon
hmm
[Music]
let me turn off my phone real quick
okay my phone is off
all right ollie's phone is off everybody
this is this is important
jt is your phone off
did you you just had to look you just
had to look how professional
it's so off it's so off i was actually
um
i was actually just looking at the back
of my case i was just uh oh sure
yep it's off now yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
all right well the game is a nice case
okay
good i i i used to have like a really
cool case and now i got like a boring
one because i got a new phone
but i still have like a little shin chan
sticker in there you gotta have that
gotta have the shin right right yes i'm
all about it okay
i'm also all about the game starting so
the game is gonna get underway ollie's
got her
glasses on which is important you need
to be able to see
up there off now the glasses are off
i spoke too soon
i mean that's uh yeah it's an anime
thing just like
yes yes yes but then rustage could hit
her with like the
anywho the game is underway and uh
we will start with a look at restage's
point of view
while we follow the players
and see what russia just thinking about
the start of his match without he
doesn't put a pawn
i don't want to develop that yet but it
definitely looks like an option in the
future just because
she's yet to push this pawn
all right see this is what i'm talking
about she always tries to go for these
checks
so i've got an idea here where i could
do this to push it back
but if i do this instead and then do
this
then she'll be completely trapped so i'm
gonna do this instead see
because this is like deceptive i feel
because you if i do this
okay what is this threatening you're
threatening this
you're threatening this which is bad
you're threatening this pawn
which is bad i might just be able to
leave that there and threaten that
i think it's even if she takes here
bishop's trapped see the bishop cannot
escape now
it's dead here it's dead there that's a
good start for rustage
a good start for rustage okay now
i obviously would lose the bishop to
that so i might as well take
here uh it doesn't free the bishop up
though
so that should just be a free pawn
it does open my queen i have to keep an
eye on that
[Music]
this is looking strong as well because
the queen can only really move
there and
it just means it's take so once i take
the bishop
this might be a good move unless this
pawn moves out i think that's the floor
okay i mean
that's fair that is a fair enough move
um if the bishop's going to die anyway
you might as well get a pawn for it
okay now that's not as good anymore
because you can do that
so
[Music]
i feel like there must be a way to like
trap this oh i could just move my uh
bishop out
again that's not good um
i undefend oh wait no that's not that's
bad
i thought i thought she caught me out
there okay that's fair you take that
you're threatening this
um but that's protected
[Music]
what's the uh better move here
um i've got ideas to like
not put if i put this here and scare the
queen off then i can put the queen
no i can't i keep thinking he's on the
wrong square
this is a threat but it's a trade it's
probably a profitable trade for me so
what i'm just going to do
is threaten the queen um
all right rest is doing his thing and uh
we're fixing some technical stuff
in the meantime but we're back and we
have the game and so jt a lot has
happened here i don't know how far you
want to go back and just scroll through
very quickly
uh so we can see how the the moves have
taken place and
uh okay i mean
it was it was an adventure here uh d4 e6
uh bishop f4 and like really playing
super solid stuff
um after you know this is like a basic
setup it's called the london system
and it's really really really strong
i'll be playing some good moves here but
then after this getting the bishop
trapped
and russell just taken advantage of that
immediately so the bishop was sacked
because you were losing it anyway so
good
good job bye ollie but now the knight is
also trapped
on e4 then i cannot go anywhere so
bishop g3 correctly choosing then you
have to stack the other piece
and then we just take a pawn and now
we're just threatening a knight here now
after d6
let's see what's going to happen yeah i
mean at least ollie has seen
like that she should get something
rather than nothing right if you're
gonna lose
material then it might as well capture
something rather than just sit and get
taken for free right
right right right right but you know um
one
one thing that i do will note is that
ollie has nine minutes on her clock and
i think she should be slowing down
especially during the
beginning parts of this chess matching
rook b5 here happening
really just slow down there's no rush
you know once you're under let's say
four minutes
five minutes that's when you should
start speeding things up and especially
when you're
at three minutes you should start really
speeding up but we have a lot of time
here
so just maybe slow down slow down all
the
um definitely not out just yet you know
you still russia still has to convert
here but russell's in a really really
good position so far
yeah let's see all these uh take on this
yeah i would say she's definitely got to
slow down here and uh yeah we'll stick
listen
is doing such a good job right now sir
i am upset right now
you have upseti that
you have upsetting the spaghetti
oh no oh no he's not going to lush in
with his queen is he
he's not going to do that right there's
no way he'd do that right
if he did it it'll be a queen exchange
so i guess that'll be okay
i mean even if you don't lose down i'll
whoosh anyways
and he's starting to think he is
taking his time think crustage
think hmm
[Music]
russ is still considering the whoosh see
a queen exchange he decided to go for it
what i don't see here is a popping i got
a difference
district right here we got a few right
here ladies and gentlemen
district do you guys know jama
jama is a japanese word that stands for
you're in the way
i can confirm that's true
okay and research can take on passant
here as
she tries to skip past his pawn
uh he could still take it as if it had
only moved one square the question is
whether or not he should jt what do you
think
yeah i i think here um although taking a
pawn is good you would
activate this stroke because then this
pawn could take back
so i wouldn't necessarily go for this i
instead i would
i see there's one rook not really
playing the game i would try to get this
active and i think
um h5 is a try to make it active because
maybe after a move like h6 then we can
play bishop here
and maybe try to get some activity on
this line and attract the king and
potentially use our rooks on the open
file
but bishop to g4 here
um i i still think that this hs movement
we saw this in the
giga versus esam game where
[Music]
you know the push of the h pawn letting
the rook
get open was uh was a very strong idea
and indeed
it's a strong idea here as well
yeah and let's see how restage feels
right now
going into what is a pretty significant
advantage
and maybe an easy end game and my
one of my biggest worries about this
game in general
playing against ollie is that i'm going
to take too much time on each of my
moves
and lose on time instead of losing
losing it's a good observation i had a
nightmare about that
okay so you're threatening that but that
doesn't matter because it's protected by
porn i think she might miss that
so i think that's how you know that you
play a lot of chess is you have
nightmares about chess so i think i'm
gonna move
the pawn up let me just think about this
and if that that takes
then i take i might just do that
wait if that takes i think it's better
to take with the rook
take out the rock of the bishop if it if
it takes
then i think better take with the rook
because then i've got better plays okay
interesting
well i will lose this
is it important for me to move this away
probably um
or do i just make my attack regardless
because this is going to attack the rook
so
but then you just take the pawn here
and i could actually also just do this
let's play smoothie one day
don't wait take your time we can wait
it's all good it's all gucci restage
he said he haven't played chess in a
while but let me tell you this
he hasn't rusted at all ha ha
i almost spit my drink on my keyboard
that was good yeah there's there's a
very beautiful mating idea here
um it's really really beautiful
after the moves that have just
transpired um
this idea of just playing bishop to f6
cutting off
all of the squares and then
bishop here is a checkmate because you
can't move right so
this is another way to go about it but i
think it's going to be a little bit
longer
if okay then king to g7 and there's one
way
to play
bishop defended by the rook
you know if oh he finds it he finds it
almost immediately
yeah and now if you take that before
bishop oh and can still take yep
right because that check was defended
now you can take the rook if you want
or you can work on your channel you can
just defend everything right yeah
because now that that covers the rook
that covers the escape square as well if
you were to move the rook from
the e-file
this is uh turning out to be
[Music]
all the ideas are there for me
i could take the rook the rook's free
now
and then it would be a rook trade which
i i might actually be fine
to trade rooks because then i got a rook
i'm low on time though i should be
really going for the checkmate
um okay
now i don't know how to pull off a
checkmate unless i've got two rooks or a
queen
so we've got a we've got a situation
here i've got to deal with
but what i'm going to do is i'm going to
try to push this pawn to make a queen
because i just i would just find it so
much easier to do so
to like get a checkmate with it i'm sure
there's a way i can get a checkmate with
these pieces
that is a threat so i should deal with
that
by
just moving my
king up
so let's say let's say i turn this into
a queen and you're going to eat with a
rook right
now you don't have any rocks but now
you're going to have a queen
me
[Music]
to get a checkmate with these
and he said he got debuffed and he oh
[__] whoa
zero mistake zero blunders zero missed
wins oh my god
i i swear i had lots of mistakes near
the end because
this is a really telltale sign of like
even if i have a peace advantage it's
really difficult for me to pull off a
checkmate
checkmate without a queen the only
checkmates i know how do you do
are putting the queen next to the king
that's protected
but that's smart i mean he recognized
that during the game and said to himself
okay like yes i've got all this material
but
it's confusing and let's just go with a
simple straightforward plan that works
which is just get a pawn promoted make
the piece you want and then
do the rest not bad
right it wasn't bad at all and honestly
rosage
also did this in the first match i
wonder you know in the second match is
he gonna take his
time and really think about the moves
because he made a lot of mistakes in the
second match
last time so hopefully he's learned from
that and he's ready
to take on the second match yeah i think
so
and i think he is ready we're ready
we're gonna see
the second game of uh ollie versus
rustic here in
uh round two of tournament arc two uh
lots of twos
i wonder if that was a plan we'll be
right back
i could have just oh no wait i can't
because there's this thing
ever mind carry on a queen exchange
all right because i had to rook with me
i didn't see that i didn't
yeah i i ah i should have moved my rook
i should have moved it
here right
because let's per se that i moved it
here
if you eat this then it'll be a
checkmate to be honest
if if this eats this
it'll probably oh no
that place oh
[Music]
i could have played it that way try
looking at the entire board ali i'll
do that i'll take my time later i'm
still going too fast i'm assuming
good game ollie maybe you needed to look
at the sticky
the tricky moves
[Music]
i think so too i think so too
that was genuinely some really solid
test gambatte
thank you thank you very much don't move
that quick take your time
right gotcha
what if i take my queen out first well
will that like surprise drastics
i think that'll be fun
like like what if wait let's do this
what if instead of doing this i do
uh
what if i do this
and then
and then maybe arrested would do
something like this it'd be like this
and also to be like what the heck you
doing and you'd be like this
and i'd be like i'm gonna do this now
all right like if he if he takes that
out i can just whom
right i think that'll scare him yeah
i'll try doing this tactic
a new tactic it won't be the book move
it'll be this one
and then he'll do something like i don't
know maybe maybe he'll wish this here
no no he wouldn't push it there he'd
wish it here
right probably i don't know
then i'd go here
and he could do something like this
like ha waiting to surprise him like
this
it's up
but he won't do that well right right he
won't do that
i'm just hoping he would you know who
knows like what if
what if you know what if
and that's quite the gambit i'll you
don't dress up cave
okay i don't rest in game two coming in
short okay guys i'm going to turn off
the live chat again i'm sorry
i'll miss you guys see you in the
battlefield
boom we will
see you and restage in the battlefield
because game two is about to begin
uh we saw some interesting strategic
thinking there jt
in the interim uh ollie
is just looking for those queen whooshes
yeah she's looking
maybe i can surprise my opponent maybe
they're not going to expect this
um and i'll be moving really quickly
here
yeah i want to see all this perspective
here she went with
let's see what she's thinking kind of
ignoring her own advice about
uh slowing down and cost her a bishop
mommy why did i take my queen out
it took the way did i take my queen out
i hope i'll be
i hope he's as freaked out as me why did
i take my queen out
i i hope that surprised him i hope
dally's made him go
yo what the heck ollie
okay um that's happening um
let's develop our pieces shall we
[Music]
he's not going to take out his queen out
too right
he's not going to take out his queen too
right
what did i take on my queen i mean it's
a good thing that i didn't take it here
imagine if i took it here i'll be losing
my queen right away
i'm petrifying him
i don't know kind of mess with my pawn
structure a little bit
this this file is just completely open
but i
okay there's the car sort so i think i'm
going to develop
here that protects this and protects
that and blocks any sort of
rook attacks on okay okay there are two
defenders on this square i've got two
attacks here
i could take that they take i take oh my
camera
i think that's a good move i don't think
there's anything else defending that
because it also attacks the uh the
knight so if they don't do anything
about it
yeah that is f so that's defended by
that
um i could just threaten the knight here
because i've got this
this here but uh if they had a king i
could have done the
fun thing but i'm not gonna do that uh i
think this is a
dead bishop i wonder if it's uh
worth it to try and save it because it
would just be a trade um
i think it i think i'm just going to
threaten the uh threaten it
i mean i'm slightly upper material but
not like enough that i think that might
have not been worth it
i kind of prefer having bishops over to
um
knights interesting
that is actually clever i didn't see
that i like that
yeah i'm now okay cool okay that's cool
because i undefended whoa hold up i set
up the queen attack on there
so i probably will just take it with the
queen let me just double check they
don't have anything else
interesting is such a great word in
chess am i right
when you forgot something it's
interesting
[Laughter]
interesting could be good it could be
bad or it could be both right
uh interesting is a very very unique
words it just
uh and here there's a lot you know after
playing c3 attacking
the the queen you were asking the queen
hey where are you going
to move and you know there are a lot of
good places for the queen
to go we can go to d3 we can go to e5 we
can go
all the way back to d8 or d6 and it's
just about a developing game we need to
keep developing and we need to
keep getting pieces if i'm already here
i i might even
try to play here try to sack upon at
some point
try to get these open lines and maybe
that'll confuse uh
rustage and maybe even e5 you know and
then uh
considering moves like queen six c6
but i i want to see what ollie's
thinking because this is this is
happening crap like
there's so much action in the first two
minutes of the game for three minutes of
the game
yeah and it seems like we've heard from
ollie herself she's going for shock and
confusion
i'm going to activate my rook real quick
after this
what what what what what's their life
stay alive
what what what what stay alive
do that threatening the queen so the
queen needs to go
or that happens
it's happening the queen once more
season two
the queen gotta move and when the queen
moves i can finally eat the night
finally get some yummy yummies yummy
yummy
ollie giving herself a hand here she
doesn't need a hand as far as the clock
goes she got nine and a half minutes
still
on her clock so definitely moving
quickly
we have a very interesting move here um
this move
e5 is a very very good move but
actually has a very interesting response
and it's a very very
nice trick it seems like you know if the
queen takes then
brook will come here and pin the queen
to the king
but they have this really nice inter
meso or in between move knight h3
you can't take it with the queen because
the bishop is taking
and you can't take it with the pawn
because then the queen will
take your queen and
if this happens it's going to be bananas
right yeah because this is a this is a
mega attack this is a tactic within the
tactic
that's six head it's one more than five
head and five's already too much
she'd probably do this actually
or that so that she can do this
interesting
well this is going to be blocking that
now
if that happens i could actually just
move there
so i might start moving my pawn up
it does have both rooks and activated
and i don't my rooks are stuck
that is not playable
at the moment but it will be once i do
this aha
yeah i knew you were gonna do that um
okay jojo
attacking that now as well oh that's
not made because the queen
but it's very close if the queen wasn't
there
which she might not be soon
this is a really good pin if i could
pull this off because even if the queen
moves out the way i win a rook
hold up what is this fan threatens that
so there's more attacks on that
so i might do this and it ruins my pin
idea
so that would be a queen
trade no longer a good move that's a
pretty
uh pretty nice looking move by ali right
um yeah um so there's a lot happening in
this position and ali is not out of it
uh okay so first of all there's this
queen capture c6 idea
where it checks the king and also hits
the rock right you just forgot to check
you win the rook
there is a really nice move that happens
after 96 because
if let's say the bishop defends after
queen c6 then we
actually have just maybe captures
threatening potentially
a checkmate so ali is
down material but definitely not out
there are a lot of tricks in this
position
and you know if russia steps there might
be some trouble
in waiting for russia i really want to
see what ali is thinking here and
what she's calculating i hope that she
sees a check but uh let's see
papa
oh my
oh is she going to find the movie here
just looking at that queen okay
it is the move here guys
[Music]
so
my
[Music]
so
[Laughter]
i'm excited i'm excited
get the glorious pop out wait that's not
a pop
no stop making noises
but you know that works
this is called advanced popping
okay this has been some serious
development here in this game
jt what happened
um the plot armor called us and said hey
uh we need to take charge now this the
flat armor is too thick here
so i thought you had your phone open for
those how could the plot armor call you
with your phone off
okay anyways go ahead well they messaged
me they messaged me um
through uh skype i still use skype so
they messaged me
wow power armor is pretty cool
so after queen e3 russet played knight
to d5
hanging the queen and then after f6
attacking the queen
hanging the pawn on g7 then i went back
and now taking the rook and now ollie is
in the lead
i'm sorry for those of you who do not
like plot armor but
it's what needs to happen here sorry
sorry guys
butt armor is too thick the armor is way
too thick here
and i want to know how rusted just
feeling right now because this is this
is rough
always blundering my queens always
blundering my queens
always and now i'm gonna lose on time
all right there are still
there is still there is still time
there's still time you gotta think you
gotta think
so this is not gonna happen that is
that's probably gonna happen and then
what do i do then do that
um this is probably the best move there
okay interesting less than 30 seconds
for rustage can't take
obviously hurry up i need to make moves
seven whole minutes for ollie
you're fine it's just a queen and two
rooks you have horses
and one rook and a bishop okay
didn't realize that was the thing
um wow and now the bishop is pinned to
the king
this is maybe a good move and she can
capture it with
check
uh it both threatens the rook and the
queen if it takes i take a i take that
um i still have that protected under 20.
25 seconds though so i could lose my
timeout
hey mama like this is where all these
shines this happened in the first match
as well
you can still go here wow
look at this
uh is it still meat no no it's not
ollie's struggling to find the maiden
one
but i feel like it's inevitable
what is this monstrosity what is this
monstrosity
can we go to blitz after this rest are
you are you listening i had
five blenders i have five blenders
that's emma wow
she did it dude it's one one we're gonna
get a third game
she did it oh oh man
oh man russell had it and then he just
like let it all
go with one simple like blunder and then
you know
you have to understand that once you
make a blunder you can't try to make up
just got to say okay i did it
what to do from here but sometimes for
beginners they make
they make the blender and then make
another blender and then it's just it's
a waterfall of blunders
oh man but she did it like whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa the flood
armor's too thick guys
knew that ollie was going to win this i
think
and i don't know who's going to win the
third game didn't tell me yet
but i don't know anymore i'm not going
to lie
i'm not going to lie anymore i i thought
that
today honestly was gonna be
kind of clear-cut but it turns out
this is anybody's match we are gonna be
right back
game three this is unbelievable i know
the crowd is hype
please uh stick around we'll be right
back
and then i blunder my queen i just
wanted my queen
i think in the first game i only won
because i did the queen trade because
then i didn't i wouldn't blunder my
queen
and then i after blundering my queen it
was just constant blunders
over and over again until the end
because i was also running out of time
yeah that was bad that was a blunder my
my idea was a blunder
and i should have just retreated that
was the actual retreat move
that i wanted to make that i did make
but just just at the wrong time
[Laughter]
[Music]
what am i doing with my life what about
this move apparently that was not good
why would why would that even be better
because it prevents this is it uh
what because i'm trying to
do that oh cause i'm trying to do that
okay
by the little things oh god i'm going
out of focus and i
i don't know how to refocus myself i
feel like most of the time i'm on this
stream i must be out of focus
please focus on me please be in focus
what do i need to do to get you in focus
do i just need to get closer
hi i'm very close
and then slowly move back
no
ah everything's going wrong today
do i play white or black in the next
game
am i allowed to ask
okay i've got to really try my hardest
in this next game
i hope the camera just focuses on me
though i hope i hope this camera focuses
ah
have i been blowing cam this whole time
i don't know why i'm asking questions no
i can't who am i asking questions too
this is i they're probably on ollie
right now the chest stream but if
they're on me
all they're seeing is me trying to focus
my camera
why well not you focus
what
what is it focusing on my microphone
that's like not
on the screen right now what are you
focusing on
what are you focusing on
do i use like a book
deciding what to focus on right now is
not just
the problem with restitute's camera it's
also
uh maybe happening on the board but i i
also have to say
like yes oh he's got his shoe
he's got his shoe this is this is a
proven technique ladies and gentlemen
you get you gotta break out the shoes
to fix your camera
it's a chart in june method
oh my lord the games are going to get
underway soon but russia needs to get
his shoe back
on and ollie needs to slow down right
she yes she won the last game but she
also
still had way too much time on her clock
and would reduce the number of mistakes
that she makes
if she gives herself more time to just
think about her next move just a tiny
bit longer right
right right i think that if she just
calms down and also rustic
calms down they both need to place a
little bit
more carefully and always to play a
little bit slower
that way you can get some better moves
out instead of just instantly playing
because right now
they're both above increment and they're
both playing
a symmetrical system so it's like
it's if anybody's game here
i would love to see a draw and see a
blitz play off
but that's just me of course of course
and commentators blessing you may get
what you want
uh your prophecies have come true and
every time
well um the stakes are high here because
if either
player wins this game they win the
pairing
and they move on and the other player
drops down to the redemption arc
let's listen in with ollie right now and
see
how she's doing still over 10 minutes on
her clock moving fast
i screwed up i screwed up
we were supposed to eat to the center
not good hustling
castling's good here to make up for that
following opening pixels
getting all the pieces out castle and
all the pieces out
this is already way better chess
and i'm loving it i'm loving this chest
yeah she's doing all right and in fact
maybe that's maybe now it's okay that
she's moving quickly because the moves
that she's making so far are principled
moves and
was that just a trade or did i miss
something yeah they still have the same
number of pieces but
where did all the bishops go
uh they were both turned off either
business just took on g3 and then h63
opening up the rook and this is a very
common london plan
um here we're looking for
yeah exactly uh the rook to the open
files
and getting those rooks active
yeah rest is doing headlines
and in some lines we we might want to
consider um some pushes on
the side like a5 a4 kind of things
and try to get our rooks
right and also get some space on the
queen side with with some ideas that
maybe like queen d5 in the future
because our queen is almost untouchable
here
and a queen in the center is a very very
good piece
yeah let's uh see resid doing his london
again as white and
uh listen in here
i feel like ollie's just like gotten
better now
like she understands all my little
london opening tricks
see this is going to be definitely a lot
closer for a game
the thing is if he takes sorry if she
takes here i take there
and actually interesting
oh there's this threat i could move this
up but then that just makes that
vulnerable
whoa
then that's just the play isn't it so
probably not do that
um i could do this what are you
threatening here this
this
this i move this pawn the knee just
takes there
i i don't want to throw it with the rook
hmm
i could not just leave it alone because
it's not doing anything
and instead there is that
it's going to be super super strong try
and go for that
there are actually wait matter of fact
there's two moves yeah if
he finds one of them
he finds one of the queen h5 um
really really strong move just
threatening
here or threatening here and
the knight on f6 was holding everything
but we might see some craziness here
because there might be some rook sacks
happening there might be some lines
opening up
it looks kind of scary if i'm ollie i
would be sorry no
and i would love to see what all these
thinking about this physician right now
oh
my goodness i can try getting my king
out of the castle
that could be a thing she has just
walked into it
okay now now rested just starting to
scare me i don't yeah
yeah does he see it
he missed it he's one of my prime
ministers
why are you gonna be so mean he sees it
now but yeah
the idea here now is that's protected by
that
and it can't go anywhere and it can't
take might be a checkmate i don't know
whenever i think i've got a checkpoint i
don't think but she'll probably do
something like
queen e7
that
he sees it ollie sees it and that
actually puts pressure on this as well
and she covers it and that's actually
good too because it still depends from
an interesting square
yeah um but
there is a a slight problem with this
uh the queen's not defended right
doesn't have a defender so if we move
this knight with check
oh yeah then that could be lights out
with uh
knight g6 check all by queen takes
right niches or knight d7 check
oh yeah for this g6 and 97
right and the queen can't capture that
knight on that square either
depends on what you want to do either
one is fine in this position
um but yeah any check with the night
winds here
and we can then win the queen because
the night is not in the way
what you have to see all that right and
it's sometimes to see moves like this
it's strange because there are pawns
covering that spirit so why would i even
think about that right but you have to
think about what happens after
right what happens after the move is
played out
you know you don't want to play cage
manchester it's only one folds
you want to think if they make a move
then what am i do right so three-fold
i make a move and make a move i make a
movement what happens there
yeah and arrestage playing a move that i
wasn't
really expecting here and doesn't seem
satisfied
that made it look like that made it look
like that's a chess.com problem
that's a chess.com problem because that
made it look like that the king would go
there
sort your [__] out chess.com
oh he didn't take i'll go do that
we're fine you heard the man
danny if you're watching we got issues
so this is a check
it doesn't do anything
and what's funny is if he doesn't find a
check
with this knight he's a good check if i
check here and the queen takes on that i
take with the queen
if i check here and then it moves back
oh the king could just move down though
and then it wouldn't be good
there's no potential for him to blunder
his own queen again
so i hope it doesn't happen but there's
a possibility
you know if this knight does not find a
good square
like a d7 or g6
then a move like knight f3 or knight g5
will blunder the queen
one more time and i hope that doesn't
happen
um but then again other there are other
great moves here
uh just like rook captures h7 it's a
fine move
yes but you know the power of your words
if you say you're
hoping something doesn't happen
we know that the commentators
tournament the anime writers behind this
behind the chest are listening
okay so he finds it and he finds it yeah
he finds the night check
and i wonder if ollie knows the
consequences of this move
i see what you did there a stitch i'm
going to move my king and then you're
going to eat my queen
that's what i thought
and then you're going to go on a killing
spree you're so mean
i've said it before you are mean you are
i mean
and you're eating my queen and nothing's
stopping you
look
nothing is stopping you except for a
check
if he goes for a check yeah but you know
i kind of like that king move in a way
because
she's recognizing that if she has
another piece available to recapture
then if the queen's traded on that
square instead
let's say if she'd taken the knight uh
rather than leaving the queen in place
then then it would have just been
an exchange that actually ended up
better for her but
it didn't quite go that way
all right and i think uh russet is
jamming here
like that that move was really good
because i would have won the queen no
matter what the move would have been
though it wasn't even a queen blunder i
just did like an amazing move
by accident okay that's definitely a
threat
spending it good accidents are better
than bad accidents
nine times out of ten but i can just
take this
and check him again check her sorry
when i say him i mean the king have you
noticed
remember this is still not over guys we
saw what happened
the plot armor might
it might be good for me to start taking
out these pawns
so i can maybe start pushing pawns up
get another queen because
garden knows i might need a backup
i can't attack these with them both in
the same row at the moment like this
but we start might we're not going to
move there obviously because that'd be a
blunder i only have four minutes
remaining so i really have got to focus
on
think think on their turn that might be
the
the play but then i'll just take there
that would probably be a better move
um but then i'll just check again on
here
uh and then what do i do with it
interesting
yeah now i can't take that okay
what does this check do for me
i think this check's good because she
then has to move the king up here and
then i can do that
yes you can do that and it would it
would it wouldn't be
a happy little accident like floyd said
in the chat with the bob rossi mode
it would actually be like a plan a
decent plan
yeah i mean let's see if you can find
the rest of the combination because
there actually
is a checkmate here and i think it's
uh czech made in a few
but you know it's it's it's only a made
in like
21 moves
giga quarter 15 16 moves yeah yeah yeah
so it's only a made in 16
you know they they both obviously see it
um
but let's see let's see what's going to
happen here i really want to
see all this perspective and what she's
thinking in this position the only thing
i can hope for right now is for
his queen to blender
i think we're all waiting for the draw
here ollie make it happen
unfortunately that move allows rustic to
trade off those
rooks if he wants which is good for
white
i'm not mistaken
um i i think you just get a free you get
a free knight
right uh rook rook to h7
and then rook to h8 uh rook's h7 check
and if the king moves to
one of the two squares and we are able
to take with our queen
[Music]
moves here then
we can just take as well and then we're
threatening checkmate
as well so rick h7 was found let's see
what the
reply is
then that's a free pawn for me
and i threatened the uh
but no i don't because you do this and
then it just takes
and i've i've lost both my pieces that
way no i can just do that
it's all good okay that's good that's
good that's good
so then i will do
this okay protecting my rook
so it'd be a rook trade which is fine by
me
it's okay with the rick trade
i think that's fine by her as well oh
now i gotta start actually getting my
pieces into the game
i gotta get rid of this that this pawn
really bad irony i started giving away
all of my pieces
oh yeah it worked pretty well with kizzy
huh
here's all my pieces take it can't move
anymore gg
i don't have any other choice but to
move
and press forward she's also got
six minutes against two
so once again restage needs a clear plan
to just convert this
otherwise he might run out of time
all the paws are pushing down now
closing in on restaurants king this
might actually spook him enough to
spending too much time thinking about it
would be hilarious is it if i get two
i get the queen and it moves down then
the queen
three tons
okay so he's counted out a simple way
forward
is what you're gonna need with two
minutes i mean that's fair
she's probably she's got more time to
think about this than i do
she's gonna try and do that
you're attacking this pawn but now
you've lost
your knife give away all your pawns
that's all you need to do
c3 b4 a5 you got this right
now i gotta get a checkmate with two
queens
that's good because it's protected by
the the knight
so it's got to go up
you have to avoid the dreaded s word
this is going to be [__] impossible
okay
[Laughter]
my god that game was the closest game
for sure you know what it's good it went
to third games because
we had kind of two one-sided games and
that game was definitely the closest
my god i'm so sorry i was so silent for
that end bit
wow wow indeed russiage has
taken the match two to one and uh
man that that was uh that was since the
end with two queens
and a king rushing up against these
white's paws and
like oh my gosh
but i had a kissy situation there for a
second
forced i would have gave up
all the pawns i would have said hey you
can have all my pieces let's have a
repeat of what happened to me last time
right
get into the blitz playoff and let's
play there i think i would have given
away a lot more than that i don't know i
may give away like uh
uh what do i have on my desk i give away
whatever for those tie breaks but
unfortunately
uh we're not gonna get that because
rustic has won the match two to one
is gonna move on in the winner's bracket
and uh we're going to have both players
in an interview in just a few moments so
stick around we'll be right back
uh interviewing ollie and rusich
what happened to me right get into the
blitz playoff and let's play that
back up i think i would have given away
a lot more than that i don't know i may
give away like uh
uh what do i have on my desk i i'd give
away whatever for those tie breaks but
unfortunately
uh we're not gonna get are you pretty
good yeah i uh
only did very good considering and uh
we're gonna have both players
in an interview in just a few moments so
stick around we'll be right back
uh interviewing ollie and russell yeah
interview time
yay oh [__] it's me
oh god ollie could have won that i
believe denali i yeah sorry chess.com
i just woke up this is not a good time
to be on the screen welcome welcome all
that was some riveting games of chess
uh we saw two titans of chess
you know uh play each other uh the the
queen blunder master known as rustage
and uh ollie who is uh
most unpredictable chess player in the
world
um which you know makes for a great game
uh no one blasters queens quite light
blunders queen's quite like rusting she
does
i love i love how the variation
in which a rustage blunders uh it's very
very interesting
always fun to watch always a new way
it's like a you know it's like uh
seeing a new animation in a video game
you're like oh i didn't see that
oh that's pretty good it's pretty nice
look at that look at that
uh rusty just has a tough game ahead of
him against gant
and i'll be playing against ollie now
which i'm sad about i don't want to play
ollie i
i do but i don't you know i don't want
to i don't want to win
against dolly so we'll see this is truly
a dilemma
ollie versus connor best game draw
accepted
three draws
just throw is that allowed am i allowed
to throw i think that's against
chess.com
terms of service i think unfortunately
isn't that insulting in some ways
bro bro moment
i'm so sad i'm so sad that all he lost i
wanted all your weight
i wanted to play rostage again
can you train her to beat me i suppose i
could
by god gun butter
ollie versus giger final let's that's
the dream that's the dream
oh man we'll we'll uh we'll try our
hardest we'll play our best
as always
sometimes the plot armor just isn't
there you know sometimes it isn't you
know
all right man while we wait for the
interviews to begin
we are just waiting we are just just
slowly waiting
slowly waiting i'm excited for the next
match too tech versus uh
kizzy i'm actually kind of hyped for
that game that game should be very
interesting i feel like they both are
very good at throwing
so it might be a back and forth like
throw fast who knows
it uh it might be interesting
[Music]
it'll be uh certainly entertaining uh
ollie ollie if you're watching this you
played very well
uh slow down a little bit you play good
chess
you think good slow down you know you
have plenty of time so much time
justin is uh wait no sorry is text
streaming right now
is he it's not genshin
oh does he don't know he's got a match
right now
does he know
he knows
it's been really optimizing uh the time
he has right now
but damn he doesn't give a [__] he's
like yeah whatever
and we are here with the players we've
got ollie
and russege hey that was uh that was an
awesome match
it certainly was
okay all right that final game was very
close in my opinion
and it was really great to see you
improve i said this at the chat but it's
really great to see you improve
throughout the games
because i i do think you naturally have
like a really good like
brain for chest you've picked it up
really well i think if you continue
playing chess
i mean you'll you'll be way better than
me
you were setting traps all over the
place for me i didn't even know what to
move
i hated you so much i was so happy with
that with that bishop traffic the first
game but then you didn't
um fall for it in the third one which
just meant
you've learned now and that will never
happen now now whenever you play against
that in the future
you you've improved which is really
great
and yeah and then i blotted my queen in
the second one
so glad when you blended your queen i
was like
finally i don't know if this was shown
but i said that i don't think there's
been a
a game in any of the tournament arcs
i've been in were blundered my queen
like like a man it has to happen at
least once
that actually leads to my first question
rustage were
were there any moments in this matchup
where
you were worried
worried yeah oh gosh um
i don't know my my was really worried i
was gonna run out of time
but i actually it was kind of
therapeutic when i when i blunted my
queen even though i was upset
i don't think i was upset as i was
against
um tech tone obviously because i
burst into tears i think i was just i
think i was just having more fun
uh and i was less stressed out and it
was so
i don't know i was just playing i was
just playing just playing
i i wasn't worried but i also wasn't
like i knew i was gonna win
i was just enjoying playing
the most important part of the of tests
and at the end of the day it is just a
board game no different
to udo
[Music]
by the way i got you something you got
me something
oh wow thank you
[Music]
i don't have any way of actually getting
it
i apologize we can pretend that this uh
puppet of a pirate is the bouquet thank
you thank you i appreciate it
you're welcome anytime thank you i have
a question for you
um ali yes
it almost seemed like you improved that
third game it seemed like
you're just playing out of your mind it
was like you figured out the london
system with one game
that's what i was saying she's a genius
did i i i hate to break it to you guys
but if i had to be very honest i did not
know what i was doing i'm being afraid
that's even better it's like it's in a
it's just in her subconscious then
she's very natural she goes into her
chest brain
like her brain had analyzed that first
game and it had now had a folder called
how to beat the london system
and in the third game that folder was
just like playing through
well you know speaking of speaking of
a folder of things where
things go we have so much fan art
in our folders of assets
uh the community has shown so much love
for you ollie that we can barely fit it
on one screen
what is it like to see the amount of
support that the community has for you
entering into this tournament
for fun i feel very welcomed you know
because uh
chess isn't my forte i didn't
i'm like unlike um everyone here who
played chess at least
once i only played it back when i was
like really
small when i was like a kid so to see
these
fan arts i feel really welcome then i
feel the support i appreciate every
single one too
it's amazing you know like
man i don't i don't even know what to
say i i get speechless when i see fan
arts
like that i didn't think that many
people would support me you know
you were definitely the favorite going
into it uh as
they say i am the mascot of tournament
arts right now
well we're happy to have you not over
right
that's correct yeah ali you are actually
going to be continuing on in the
tournament you've moved down to the
redemption arc
and of all opponents you will be playing
sea dog va and i have a feeling that
you're
gonna be pretty excited for that match
is that right
i am i am invited and
i am ready to lose
can i can i can i just say can i just
call out connor right now because i
know what he's watching i know he's
watching he's definitely watching he's
titled his stream
watching ollie play chess what about me
dude
i thought you were friends i've slept on
your floor man
what is watching ollie play rusty i you
know
i see how it is
look at sea dog right there
he's all flustered
listen let's all just get along let's
let's um
let's sit down and maybe apex together
and make
makeup
that's true there's always apex
uh i want to ask you about your next
match as well i don't remember
if you faced gigguk in tournaments
so but i will say this i will say this
and it is in the vod
when gant and connor played each other
for the first time and people asked me
which one of them
is going to win and i'm not afraid to
say this though after i've been slighted
by corner instead conor has had more
experience with chess but i think gans
is naturally better at chess than connor
is
and therefore i just think he has that
he just
connor's got monkey brain gant's got
like engineer brain
you know so i i am more scared to uh
face gantt than i was ever to face
connor
he shot his [__] well
[Laughter]
we're gonna remember that you said that
rustage this exists on the internet now
forever
you literally just said that connor's
watching
[Laughter]
oh gosh jt before we let the players go
and get into the next match i want to
give you the floor for any last
questions you might have
um i don't have any
questions but rostage do a lot of work
i want you to focus i want you to stop
worrying so much
in your games you know you have great
ideas and you have
really really good talent when it comes
to thinking so
keep that up um you are spending a
little bit of
you spending a lot of time in the
opening which is what i like but when
she once you see five minutes
then start playing fast and what i
recommend before your next match is just
maybe play some one-minute chats
right oh [__] we're gonna try to really
just try to play fast
fast you're used to playing fast right
that way you have the best chance
against garth yeah and devotional
support
and ollie your run is not over yet you
still have some games to play
and you need to just focus you know and
you you're playing extremely fast so i'm
going to give you the opposite
i'm going to tell you to slow down a
little bit you know the way you played
your third match
is probably the way you should play
every match and the way you came back in
your second match
surprised me so keep that up
you're are both very talented
individuals and i just want you
to do your best and i know that you're
going to make
both of us proud and everybody that's
watching the chat round
if i play too fast and uh if i play too
slow and olly
plays too fast if we were to combine we
would be the best chess player
we would be if we were there fusion
dance that you can do here if we did
like
like weird hybrid we would be
magnus carlson easy someone we need a
fan art of this
place yes yes the challenge has been
made
community at home we need fan art of
ollie and rustige
uh guys thank you so much both of you
and uh we will see you again in uh
just a few days so thank you so much
that was great chess and uh
we'll talk to you soon thank you so much
and there you have it the players are
excited for their next matches
and uh we have it ali is going to be
playing sea dog va
and uh russage will be playing gig in
his next match so
uh wow wow uh
both players very very a positive
and uh very complementary of one another
and jt
um that was a satisfying match i i don't
you think
um yes we didn't get the the blitz match
like i wanted
but i it was really really good the way
russet took that first match was like
wow okay he had some traps he executed
he did everything almost perfectly right
i want to say that that's one of the
best games that i've ever seen rustic
play the second game he was playing well
but he didn't convert he was
you know he was maybe too scared of the
opponent's right and then let go of his
queen
like he said he's under the queen every
single match
so just calm down don't blame the queens
anymore
and don't let your opponent come back
when you have an advantage the hardest
thing to win
is a one game and i'm ready for this i'm
just
super super ready for this and i'm
excited for our next match
yeah our next match the stakes will be
even higher
because one of these two players
techtone
or kizzyk will go home and this will be
the end of their tournament if they lose
the match
so uh stick around we'll be right back
and when we
come back tech tone versus kizzy k
see you in just a moment
even higher i'm not because one of these
two players tech tone
or kizzy k will go home and this will be
the end of their tournament that's me
i'm that guy i'm going home
see you in just a moment unless unless
perhaps i'm a god
i don't believe i don't it's the
underdog hey you can't look at me
but i'm gonna get clapped i forget clap
for her it sucks
just don't die in 10 minutes that's the
plan
but knowing me i'm gonna think that i'm
good and then i'm gonna i'm gonna get my
head slapped off my goddamn shoulders
i mean what can i say i can only play
the best game of chess that i can play
and i'm gonna hope to god that that's
enough because that's all i got
that's all my god dude i'm terrified
unless
unless unless
when the odds are stacked against me
my back against the proverbial wall
against all odds i pull out the trump
card
the magic cylinder to the blue eyes
ultimate dragon counter attack direct
points
to the light points will techtone be the
man to beat
will kizzy k be kizzy days
of the past who knows i don't know who
knows
what the future holds for me but hustle
loyalty respect is all that i need
and today
mama ain't raised no quitter today i
ascend
above and beyond to peaks not recognized
by mere humans because i am not
a mere human i'm a genetic freak
with a normal human being you have a 50
50 chance of winning but i am not a
normal man
i am a specimen factor that in for my
odds against kissy k
it's a 25 to 75 chance
of me winning 75 in my favor
kissy k today at backlash
i'm bringing home the gold and you one
two three better be devoured
by the mere thing you fear the most
the hippo
i don't need shady tactics i don't need
underhanded ploys what i need
is the loyalty to my lineage
to the people who brought me from the
ground up
who believed in me when i didn't even
believe in myself jt
today i'm making you i'm making you
proud
all right anywho uh time to get my dick
slapped off my chest
let's go
we'll see i know it'll be dope
i would love that listen
wow that was like a intro to a
wwe match you said on uh off screen
there jt
that was probably one of the most
amazing segments i've ever seen in my
life and uh
becky you've already made me proud with
that intro we have to live up to it
jt is proud you've heard it you have to
make it true and you know what hey this
this kind of reminds me of uh him
psyching himself out for that first
match between
uh uh him and uh rustage
putting on the jacket with the pin and
running for president you remember that
oh yeah oh yeah
i i think he used to be there's a lot of
things that actually techie used to do
or text on he used to be
a wrestler he was uh in music as well he
did uh professional
music so um really i did not know
exactly yeah yeah he has a
little bit he does a little bit of
everything and does it well
i mean that makes sense kind of sounded
like a rap earlier
i don't know right right i thought i
don't know if it was intentional
but it was pretty good either way
it definitely gave me the wrestlemania
vibes you know when i was a kid i used
to watch
wwe all the time uh back when i was like
when i was a kid basically dinosaurs
were still alive and it was
called the wwf but i'll do you remember
yeah
before that dreaded wildlife federation
showed up
right right right so i'm dating myself
here but um
it was that was an amazing intro i need
to find that skill in me and say
this night what's tuesday today
oh wait
something's gonna happen so i'm super
excited to watch um
gizzy and um techno play
you know it's going to be such an
amazing match and i'm ready what are
your thoughts about this
i mean this is going to be fantastic
because kizzy k
is a professional fighting game player
uh representing panda global
esports organization and kizzy himself
if any of you
out there are fans of games like guilty
gear
or dragon ball fighterz then you know
all about
the kind of talent that it takes to rise
to the highest levels in those
games and kizzy uh has to have the
instincts
for uh not just that but also
i i feel like we have heard in the
lessons with these players from the fgc
that a lot of those skills translate
well to chess
uh and so we're gonna see i think we
already kind of saw
kizzy uh showing some natural challenge
for chess in his first match and
and we're gonna hopefully see that again
just like we're seeing some lip sync
again from japanese tutor
oh yeah yeah yeah exactly i know you did
karaoke but i didn't know that you did
lip sync stuff
i did a lot i like i'm actually i
actually love doing karaoke
it's one of my favorite pastimes
actually uh when i used to live in japan
i used to go almost every day
to karaoke uh maybe i won't bother
you with my singing although it's
beautiful but
maybe maybe in the grand final maybe in
the grand final
um let's not promise that okay
so yeah i think this is going to be an
amazing match i know that kizzy is
he's been putting in a lot of work and i
know that saxon's been putting in
a lot of work so i'm just like super
excited to see what the fruits of their
labor
is yeah well let's uh get right to it
the game is going to begin any second
kizzy uh won the coin flip earlier in
the day off camera and uh
we'll play with the white pieces in the
first game so
uh get ready get set uh kizzy k
and tektone is now underway
and we'll start with uh kissy's
perspective here
with d4 brought he
right off the back work
first match tonight with some jams
yeah and we're getting our pieces
developed here by kizzy um
e4 would be the natural reply if your
opponent is not taking center it is your
duty
to take the center
yeah and i mean we were going to see
that with the hippo right the tech tone
is going to play for a long range
strategy
right right so the actually it's the
opposite because we're not having pawns
in the center
we're actually going to fight for the
center when we're ready to fight for the
center
and we're actually waiting for white to
overcome in the hippo we're waiting for
our opponent to over commit
to a strategy right and we're waiting
for our opponent to
push too far so that we can take
advantage and then we know where
where we need to strike with an
effective pawn break or an effective
question in the center
so here this is all stuff so pretending
that the knight needs to go there not
developing the bishop because we know
the bishop needs to go
here so even though we haven't gone over
this
i think that he feels his position now
yeah he feels he
looks comfortable maybe sounds
comfortable
damn this [__] up i'm in no rush
you do you spaghetti man you want to
waste a turn backing that bishop up
you tell me am in no rush i can do
this [__] all day
[Music]
i know right now this man he's reaching
out to every local
okay there you go uh here we go
best move back up coward
you're damn right you're damn right
put some respect on my name
take your time buddy this is literally
the set play that we've talked about in
the info
two kings
and we gonna do the same thing
we're gonna do the same thing we're
gonna get you to back up
we're gonna get you to waste another
turn you love to see it hercules
hercules
i'm ready take it kill my horse
because you know you know i'm taking
this pawn i'm about to a6 this [__]
we bout to a6 this [__] you better back
up before you get
slapped up
[Laughter]
i love coming she's talking with the
hippo wow
i mean hey it's working for him right
yeah
so the reason i went with the hippo with
tech is just you know this is a play
that we get all of our pieces out
you can go for the structure uh at
almost any point
and it's literally just that play we
most beginners are going to over push in
the center and they
want some action to happen we don't want
actions to happen until we
need it to happen so basically when all
of our pieces are developed
so here i think texon is in great shape
and even as black remember white starts
up
with a small opening advantage uh black
neutralized that advantage because of
the you know a6
moves and h6 moves and getting
everything to the center so now
we're ready to push whenever we want to
and so move like
a6 just completing the structure
and then castling and then going for
whatever we want to do after that
yeah and maybe the comfortable
opening sequence for black also
expressing itself in the time advantage
that techtone has right now over kisi
who's at seven minutes to techtone being
over the amount of time he started with
above
10 minutes and uh let's see how it's
maybe affecting kizzy's attitude so far
about this
this game
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
bro i need that horse to move bro too
many horses
just gonna do this
man a kissy k now under six minutes um
techy might be looking to win this match
purely on the clock
yeah i mean he's not even caring about
you know what's the best movies like
i'm going for set play and that is it
we had a bishop trap earlier but you
know what in the in the hippo
we're just going to beat you slowly
doesn't matter that this is the best
move we know what we need to play we
know what we need to get
to and we know what we need our pieces
to do and
he's just employing it perfectly like i
i don't think he's made one
mistake yet and we're literally just
just waiting um and as i say that the
commentators
um oh yeah knight is now loose
on e7 correct oh a7 and d7 g7
oh no both of them were loose and this
is this is not
looking good couldn't move that queen
there just yet you hate to defend them
or play knight f6
[Music]
it seems i've made a grave error in
judgment
well [__]
uh that is
really bad that is super bad
but i believe
we messed up one time i didn't see it
he can take both
oh no
oh [__] wait [__]
uh i saw you big man
[__] no oh
no oh i'm an idiot
oh [__] i'm an idiot okay hold up all
right we [__] up
don't worry hold up don't worry hold up
this is uh this is all part of my plan
we'll be all right
we're gonna be okay because the
important thing is we have time on our
side
we're gonna be all right we just gotta
we just gotta cut our losses
take the take the [__] take the rook
bro take it
it's all part of the plan jt i don't
know if you know this
this is all part of the plan um
this is the first time that uh this part
of the plan was shown to me so uh
but i'm glad that this is part of
somebody's plan it's a variation
and actually this might be very very
interesting
wow the gizzy didn't take
yeah he needed to play b5 there actually
oh no i want to go back to texas i
honestly want to see what he's thinking
about because
he's not under the second night
all right so you know what you got that
that's good enough for me you know what
you do your thing
you got this big man you're doing great
you're doing excellent next time i'm not
going to give you so many free pieces
next time we're going to be more aware
yup
i mean i kind of could just
do this right he's gonna move that
here from over here
this is very very interesting just want
to take the goomba away point where
okay so he did there might be something
that's involved here okay
i like hearing some if thens from kizzy
k but i'd like to hear them from
you as well what's going on here
um so here if white is not careful here
and plays a move like let's say that e4
then we have
bishop captures anything on this line
and then we have captures here
[Music]
spicy so this bishop just
get out of the way and they were able to
take this piece here
but if bishop takes f3 then we have this
intermezzo mission captures e6
takes on e6 and then queen cannot take
on f3 oof
does not see it and bishop practice e6
is now a free piece kizzy
is doing an impressive job here
of breaking through the indestructible
hippo
oh yeah oh yeah let's oh let's see what
kids he has to say about this position
wait
[Music]
what
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
okay i'm losing my time though bro look
how much time i don't have
wildlife's gotta be this way man
this is crazy dude wait
[Music]
where
he's gonna take this right
it's gonna take this but then he has to
move this so
then i know actually he's going to take
it it's going to
move
[Music]
i actually messed up
actually i didn't messed up
wait a minute now wait a minute what is
this move from tech tone
king g6
yeah king g6 is a move i mean trying to
get out of the pin right
i'm going to get out of the pin there's
a lot of pieces on
the the kings are attacking the king's
side and
what is this move oh my oh my
oh my indeed
[Music]
huge vulnerability here
but he was about to play the recapture
like he already
had that in mind sorry
i think i choked nevermind
i spoke too soon that's garden if you go
there i take there
i think i'm gonna just take that i'm
gonna just take it
okay so you take my pawn but i'm not
really worried about that i could go
take your horse right now i think that's
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna limit his
pieces
yeah i'll just trade i'm a limited he's
gonna take my queen
no he's not dude
take those thank you
[Laughter]
it is the uh roller coaster bro i
shouldn't have looked there bro
damn it i played myself bro
[Applause]
[Laughter]
because you say i played myself you're
supposed to play your opponent right
wow this looks like another
oh my gosh
wow what a first game
this is an amazing game and i don't even
like this is just a free piece on on c3
here but i really wonder
what the players are thinking because
this is a from going from
totally losing to totally winning can
techy
actually convert now or kids is kids
gonna come back now
wow this is wild let's listen into tech
tone
to blunder and of course if there's an
interview after this i'll say well it's
all intentionally really
truly is you know it's all part of my
ploy
uh that does no you just take that
gobble it up yum yum yum yum yum
yummy yummy yummy in my tummy
yeah put me in check huh you dirty dog
all right uh-oh i think i'm gonna
squeeze on being on white spaces this
bishop could be a massive [__] to me
this is gonna be a test of kizzy's
tactical awareness here
yeah ninety-five checks big man i think
the next thing i wanna
do is i wanna move my rook to uh c8 and
then blast this [__]
i cannot wait to see texas reaction but
he misses
he's playing h3
i'm ready kissy oh my gosh this game
that does nothing both players are
playing way too fast here
this is getting wild
this is back and forth
both players are going back and forth
and you can valuation marco
like this like i'm probably closer just
up and down up and down up and down
and my emotions are like that roller
coaster up and down up and down up and
down
gosh it's like a seesaw what is
happening okay so techtone has gotten
out of the danger of the fork so
now 95 comes too late to win material
um but
wow i mean keeping the tricky knight and
there's another fork actually
knight takes b6 right
what again is another fork it's a test
of
kizzy's tactical awareness here
and he looks at the night again where
can they go
but ops maybe for the bishop oh jeez
what's gonna happen
i gotta start matching i honestly don't
have any tutor bro if you hear me dog
i promise you i did not do it
it was the spirit of chess.com that
wanted me to lose
the spirit whoa
whoa i like how they're both shouting me
out saying hey jc look at this
man
[Music]
you know what it's never over until it
is over
we we know this
my goombas
you got a minute to move those goombas
kizzy
he called you out jt yeah he did call me
out
but um this
this is such an amazing match like it
went up down up down and there were
several
opportunities to make a comeback make a
play
i wonder how that's gonna translate into
the second game because there are a lot
of
there's still a lot of opportunities to
blunder as we saw
so i don't know who's gonna win i don't
i
have no idea yeah i mean kissy only has
30 seconds but
in a way it's never too late in terms of
the play that we've seen so far
for both players uh
a tech doesn't look concerned obviously
i think he sees the kids he has low time
and he's got tons
let's listen yep
feeling good
[Music]
pump
oh jeez
missing an opportunity
rook h1 or even a queen swing over
but it's okay i mean you know because
he's under 20 seconds here so
kind of anything you play is good right
don't move
right right just just i hope there's no
stalemate here but
aside from stalemate anything you play
is good you had to say it huh you just
had to say it
yeah i i have to say that's it decto
goes for a queen oh my gosh look at the
queen in the rook of the pods
it's like destiny
[Music]
any move that's not a check just scares
me so bad how's that not checkmate
well white has pieces that it can move
legally so
okay we're not quite in that territory
watch me stalemate those it'll be epic
that'll be sick bro it's calling it out
stale for content
do it uh i'm gonna just move my king out
of the way
push that pawn kissy okay
yeah because he has to push on he has to
give it away the palm there's no there's
what that pawn can do
if i were techy i would not even just i
would not even touch that phone
just let him take whatever he needs to
take how do we do this
yup
oh my gosh the struggle is real oh
i mean as long as you keep checking
don't you keep checking you win
yep
what's funny is because he's gained a
lot of time on his clock just moving out
of checks
let's see if we'll move up again for me
move up
thank you
[Music]
it goes up
[Applause]
let's go dude
wow techy he does it he does it
kizzy is kissy celebrating for techie
what does he say
oh man
[Music]
i am no longer the king of games i am
the king of throws bro
oh kizzy it's not over man it's not over
it's definitely not over we have this
match event if kizzy can get
this match going and get a win here then
we're gonna be able to
see a third match so i can't wait until
that happens
i can't wait until the next match i mean
like this match was like up and down up
and down swing swing swing the
evaluation bar going up and down up and
down my emotions up and down up and down
them calling me out
just up because they just kept calling
me out but
i i i i can't wait for this game
this tournament even though it is one of
my favorite
things ever i need to go to my therapist
after this oh my gosh dude the way
the chest that gets played the the
stakes and the matches oh lord
we're going to break so i can go breathe
we'll be right back
kissy k what do you do kizzy k
[Music]
panda kissy k oh they play pokemon and
stuff
oh actually they just do all sorts of
stuff so they are
professional player for panda sponsored
by arcade stock
pog oh they play fighting games dope
okay that's respectable fighting games
are hard as [__]
all right what's next
i'm gonna do the same thing
only this time i'm not gonna blunder my
[__] hey your thought y'all thought i
threw it
i told you he's gonna blunder his queen
on move 34
and i'm gonna take it i already seen
this episode
i've already watched it this is a rerun
this is a rerun we already seen this
[__]
we're going to do it again
we going 2-0 because
the first round was a fluke okay
i was too busy being distracted by
rustage's beautiful eyes
yo heaven shampie they're gonna stop my
dude
[Music]
that's loud as [__] nintendo
all right let's do some yoga
[Music]
take all of the negative chakras
focus and let them fly
strength of a dragon heart of a
groundhog
spirit of a dragon focus
try being high from the great hippo clan
of jt we go even further and
strike nice [__]
oh yes okay
okay i'm ready
we better run it back back to back there
won't be a game three
there will not be a game three because i
want to eat my pizza
so i'm gonna need is i'm gonna need to
strike hard and fast
i'm gonna drink hard and fast
like a like a 20 pack of chicken nuggets
from mcdonald's to an obese man
through the heart
also nice ass cheeks panda man looking
good
next one in two minutes
hey
[Music]
wave to the camera techie wave to the
camera
wow dude uh techtone
just delivers he delivers in terms of
uh i don't know i think the grand
masters can take a page out of
techtone's book
in terms of prep right getting
emotionally ready to crush
what do you think i mean did you not see
the the pulling of the
bad chakra and shooting it and the yoga
poses
and then the great hippo technique oh
man
that was that was instruction right
there i'm also seeing what what am i
saying what is this
[Music]
never give up i i watch this at least
three times a day
three times a day before i try to pay my
taxes
and eventually fail never give up
come on kizzy we got time
to [__] around let's do it up
uh we have time to get the games going
let's do this what do you think that was
amazing
i mean i think techie's going to go and
check his weight in this game he's going
to go straight for that
hippo and you know when you play for
white it's the hippo attack when you
play it for
black defense overall i just call it the
hippo it's a
it's opening that i that i made up and
uh it works i
show it to all of my students who have
trouble with openings they're like
you know mr japanese tutor that's what
they call me mr japanese suitor
what should i play in the opening i'm
having so much trouble and i say
like this i guess you get all your
pieces out wait for them to push in the
center
and then you counter attack and if they
don't put a push in the center and
they're not attacking you get your
pieces up to the best squares possible
and then you push in the center and you
destroy them
dang jt um i might need a hippo lesson
from you then
it might be time it might be time yeah
because it
is a movement and some yoga lessons from
tech tone
right right right
wow wow wow all right let's uh let's do
our first check-in in game two
maybe if kizzy k what do you think
mm-hmm let's do it
if anything it's a good excuse for some
cat jams in the chat
oh yeah i love cat jam igem is like
by far my favorite emo
you have to be hat jam or tech w
or cat pop fake allah
yeah there wasn't enough pops in her
game for fortunate
i'll tell her on twitter that she needs
more popping yep
good coaching yep yep
let's see and again we just have more
time for
protection than izzy has to kind of
figure this out
you know moving a piece twice in the
opening isn't the best but i think
his position you know he might be trying
to break with e4
yeah man i mean wow like legit
i kind of think now we're we're speaking
too soon here
because kizzy can win this game
and we can have a third game because he
can win that and then win the match
but part of me wonders
if this hippo is something esam
would be ready for if techtone moves on
because it seems to be working
so the thing about the hippo is is that
one played correctly even the best
attackers cannot get through right when
you understand what you need to play
and what your opponent's best reply is
not even the best and most skilled
players like i i played this
at different levels and different elo
and
it just works honestly because it's
something
this is something that most people have
not seen before and they have to think
on the fly where we're just
developing and
maybe maybe he'll be ready or maybe he
won't but that's
something that we have to find out in
the next episode
sounds like dragon ball z yeah in the
next exciting episode of dragon ball z
question for you jt i know you have a
youtube channel where you post
um lessons not only that you've had with
tournament arc players and others but
also just lessons in general that you
things you want to share and and things
you want to teach with chess
do you have you made hippo videos
for your youtube channel yet oh yeah
yeah yeah i have made
um i i did one with i posted one with
tekto
in it and there is another one on it but
i've done a lot of
opening reviews about a lot of things
and what i think about them
um so it's very interesting thank you
for mentioning
yeah uh my very people people should
definitely check you out on youtube
but also uh we should check out this b4
move tech tone not just playing well in
the opening but also
tactically he hit both the queen in the
night i mean this was
this was nice that's fair yeah
okay but in here i can punish this i go
there he can't take back
uh if i go here and he takes okay so if
i go here
i can't really do much
i think that is the best play though
it's cool he had something good but he
stopped himself from just
taking right away right there when you
find a good move
look for a better one kind of approach
right right and
in this case actually i do not like
taking here because we
we lose our hippos bishop and we don't
want to lose the bishops in the hippo
we saw how effective they were in the
previous game right
so we have to be very very careful
about what we play see this is where
this is where the difference in skill
between you and me
really shows jt okay because
taking is my kind of chess
fair enough but i think you know the
most important move maybe it's just like
rook b1 right
rook b1 and then we're able to maybe
play c4 at some point
or after rook b1 maybe we're able to
play bishop
a1 and maybe push for b5 or just castles
and you know h3 and it's all set up
right we don't have to destroy our
structure
right now but i do feel like you gave
the knight away
in with b4 right so actually this one
maybe you should be staying on b3 and
maybe just h3 and
or you know castles and then h3
uh i think here rook b1 is rook b1
or rook a2 are the only moves in this
position
um and knight b3 decent
decent move um you say hey let's trade
knights i'm going to
ruin my pawn structure a little bit but
at least i keep my bishop
not a bad move not a bad choice um and
we still have
pressure in the middle so overall
pretty much a net positive i think okay
so neither you
nor techtone play the bad moves
that i somehow cannot resist
[Laughter]
simply irresistible but uh techtone
resists the urge and let's listen in
because
he may not alright be able to resist
this
next capture kissy k
[Music]
if he takes with the bishop i just take
there no
[Music]
what the issue with this move is
not so is that like the double pawns
seem to be the
the immediate threat but there's a
simple response
right
yeah and here after the after the queen
just moved right because
obviously we can't say here because the
queen is defending uh the b3 square so
we
lose a queen here so like let's say
after queen e7
or after this and between b6 uh then
we're
actually able just to castle and keep
playing our set play
just in peace commentators curse
come with us i'm sorry i'm sorry i
didn't that's
that's my fault can we have a redo
take back
kissy stream just catching up
do it i did it i knew it
i knew it i knew it i knew it why did i
go to button bro
i start scrambling man oh my god
i start scrambling
oh my god
oh my god scramblex dude
wow yep that happened that was the thing
that happened
yeah i mean it's unfortunate because i
think because he was doing extremely
well
right until that point i think the
position was equal all you have to do is
keep developing your pieces
um but that's hard and it's really
really hard
when you know you're under pressure and
you're down in game
and i get it especially when you know
it's chess as well
every movement matters
but you have to be diligent and
tenacious
you're right
i i wonder what texan's gonna do i
wonder what he's thinking about in this
position
definitely got a contemplative look on
his face
you're not gonna give me your rook too
are you he might just be
still confused and shocked after that
queen
are you gonna give me your rook too
i don't okay
yeah i probably would have done the same
thing that's probably a good idea
all right i know i know
all right let's let's do this
if i move up there i'm down to trade
pieces at this point
okay
good awareness good creating pieces is
good when you're up yep
[Music]
what's the plan here kissy
yeah obviously the plan for techie here
is he knows he's up in material so
let's get a trade going and uh we'll
just
take away some some uh some options
right make it even harder for kizzy to
fight back
and actually this um rook
queen and rook battery is actually
called
the gun or ali atkins gun or alekhine's
gun whichever one you want
but it's a known strategy and he was
able to figure that out
over the board is he the new uh
nimsovich or alejakin or any of this
old you know stronger players i wonder
what's going through his head i wonder
how did he come up with this idea it's a
beautiful idea but
it's just so strong and wow he's amazing
with his chest right now
understanding like the principles yeah
techtone
is really showing up today uh in terms
of energy in terms of the quality of his
moves his management of the clock is
opening
uh wow just techtone is playing so
strong for somebody who earlier today
was certain he was not going to walk
away from this this pairing
uh the victor here
this is good stuff
yeah and here there are
there's a little bit of mess here but if
you can navigate through that mess i
think that
it's gonna be an easy road just you have
to keep
keep pushing keep your pieces developed
make sure that your king has
lift or space to get out of any
potential back ranked mates
and make sure that your pieces are
active first and foremost
yeah and uh again trades continue to be
good for tech tone
he knows that the path forward here
should be straightforward if he
sticks to it and uh we'll see
how confident he is to wrap this up
okay you want to take that you can take
that do you want to take my pawn
and it it's never over till it's over
again because he could come back here
all right
um because he just went back a bit okay
with this
yeah that lined up to do nothing i can
go there
which puts the bishop in danger which
i'm down for maybe he doesn't see that
is this balling his gig is safe
he takes it no matter what i get a good
trade let's take it with bishop now
which i don't get a good trade but
that's fine
[Music]
wait don't i have checkmate
oh [__] wait hold on this don't check
right now
wow cuz he's gone off the deep end here
oh
let's check right now
you have to sacrifice your horse now and
he'll play back there
oh nice checkmate okay let's go
all right cool if he would have played
back then he could have prolonged it but
all right cool
hoggers pokers
[Music]
to throw i don't play
myself bruh
damn wow
ah kisly obviously
uh disappointed there and unfortunately
that punched his ticket out of
tournament arc 2
uh being in the redemption arc if you
lose your pairing there
you you uh you go home that's
unfortunate but
uh tech tone just man he really
delivered all the way around
jt man that match what do you what can
you say
i mean i i think it was a lot of
nerves that because he had he had a
great position he had great ideas
um but it just let it go like that the
second game
the queen he just wondered the queen and
that was pretty much the only mistake he
made
unfortunately unfortunately that was the
only mistake he made
so i'm i like the chest that was played
but would love to see um more um
i just want to see another match because
that was so that was so good like it's
just i kind of feel disappointed that it
ends here
you know what i mean yeah i felt like
his position and his play was so good
yeah i mean kizzy really has shown
amazing
growth in his chest kill despite
tonight's result
and we will talk to both of the players
about that in just a moment so
uh please stick around and we will be
back
with uh kizzy k and uh techtone
see you in a second all right
amazing growth in his chest kill despite
tonight's results and uh we will talk to
both of the players
about that in just a moment so uh please
stick around
and yeah i mean each time just plays
these times blunder pieces that's what
you oh [__] it's me oh god
you sound blunder doesn't blunt the
pieces so i mean it's a lot easier
to play against who is someone who does
do tons of blunders
[Applause]
net loss of seven points that's what
you're gambling welcome to the casino
new stream oh yeah i should oh god
that's i'm going to hear me
stream i totally forgot i totally forgot
trying to dodge you excited for our
gamey sam you excited
you excited i'm high i just don't want
to use
my brain much you know i like i like
just winning you know it's fun
but now i have to now i want to play
rustage and beat rustage
gotta the audacity of russians trash
talking
how dare how dare rusted
just win kick i am that's gonna be fun
as hell
good it'll be a good game it's gonna be
a good game this should be a game that's
for sure
but uh you'll have fun i'm sure you get
to relax tomorrow you can have fun games
wow definitely what's now they think of
the ten subs wow thanks so much man
connor is cursed rooting what do you
mean i root for people to win and
they've been winning what do you mean
if one person loses it's not cursed man
guys come on
just play perfectly no problem no
problem
we both can yeah i'll be nice nice i got
stuff to do tomorrow as well so i'm glad
that i have a hard game
another video shoot so i'm playing first
tomorrow i think if
i'm correct and then i have to uh
go like i can't really hang around much
what do you mean alia's dark horse
exactly
but ollie plays fast so the game will be
fast
ollie plays super fast
yeah i play after yeah exactly
you're playing the second game tomorrow
no i asked them to swap it because i
actually have a video shoot that i have
to do tomorrow
uh that i can't miss and i told them i
was like hey
if i run out of time i have to just go
like unfortunately
i i can't play uh
so yeah luck in your games con
rustage what i'm gonna
i'm i want to play you now rastage
you're going to lose wrestage
i need to play your roster we all play
for sure good good
you're just a stepping stone in this
story rustage
rust is being supported and we're back
with the players
uh kizzy k and dr evil
it looks like what's going on over there
techtone
you know last week everybody counted me
out they told me techy you'll never make
it in a million years
but today i proved all my doubters
incorrect once again by doing the
impossible
being the greatest player of chess of
all time kizzy k
my god what a spectacle
well it certainly was impressive and um
uh kizzy i wanted to start actually with
you um
we want to know what your
uh preparation was like for this match
and
you know you had some time to prepare
between uh the last weekend and this
weekend and
what were the areas that you focused on
uh in order to
put your best foot forward in this match
so i think
uh one of the biggest things that i
was having an issue with before i start
i just want to let c dog know that i
lived up to my name as the best thriller
so
put some respect on the name please
thank you very much i am here
i am mr brady himself uh check out my
rings
but yo honestly real talk i actually
felt like my attacking was really really
bad like
overall i felt like after i opened uh i
kind of felt like
i didn't really know what i was doing
afterwards in terms of like
objective and like uh type of like what
setup that i should be trying to do
uh i was basically trying to basically
um feel out like oh uh
you know like testing out like what what
ideas that i had and
uh from the experience from the other
games that i was playing and uh
basically like
i still had an issue where i looked at
the time and i was
like folding a little bit in terms of
that and uh
when one thing crashed like uh i i
i lost track of like what i should have
done next because
of something just not processing
correctly and uh basically i just really
didn't bounce back from that
but uh i basically was trying to
uh be a little bit more like aggressive
but
the problem was is like when i was being
aggressive i
was looking i still was looking too
forward to things where
i should have been focusing on one thing
so my whole
goal basically was uh be more
in the front but i still wasn't uh
sound with my game plan basically well
and after that
the world blew up in my in my world you
know i mean
well i will say that i think part of it
jt you can definitely chime in to this
more than i can
is um that techtone
chose an opening that i think makes it
just
difficult not just i i mean for anybody
to
play attacking chess against um jt
tell us more about that yeah so the
opening that
uh techy chose um we had a lesson on
it's called the hippo
and the hip was basically meant for
anybody to
that is trying to attack you you're just
saying okay i'm just going to develop my
pieces to good squares i'm going to
castle and then i'm going to do what i
want to do after and it's very very hard
to attack and this kind of gameplay it's
you have to have a strategic
understanding of the position
and it's very hard to get with that in
10 minutes right like you have to be
able to understand what's going on in 10
minutes and it's very very difficult
when you don't know what your point is
going to play but exactly that was step
play
that said i thought you played amazing
chess
do not count yourself out like you were
playing extremely good just in the first
game and in the second game
right the first game you had two nights
right
you were you're up basically two nights
um
and you know it was unfortunate that you
know you
let the opponent come back but i i was
like you're putting on a show for us
and then when techie came back i was
like oh man oh no
don't throw it really so you know what
it is it's like
to be re to be fair with you like
because i know that i'm like all right i
need to focus on this now because i
already kind of got this done
i i i take the time to focus on like
one piece at a time before the puzzle
comes together
so you know obviously uh as the game
progress i have to learn things off the
fly of like what i'm doing
so sometimes i make very bad decisions
but i feel like the only time for me
to learn is to make those bad decisions
right so for me
like i actually and i'm also like pretty
happy that i got it further but
i just think it's very funny that i'm
still like fold i folded it like on the
crucial moments
when i was like okay i never i haven't
seen this uh this
thing before but let me try something
out and then like you know i thought it
said what was that you know but uh it
was
fun that i at least got two pieces of
the puzzles down and now i just gotta
i just have to have better formation in
a lot of situations that i feel like
that's the biggest thing that i've been
seeing
and even before get even even when like
i'm looking at plays i'm like oh
i definitely about to lose right now or
like oh i definitely see where i messed
up now and
stuff you know it's a learning process
you know yeah
well i mean despite the results i i
still feel like we saw some very
quality moves from you in both of those
games and tech it seems like maybe
we got the nodding going on you might
agree were there moments in this match
that you were worried
oh yeah are you kidding me when i
blundered both of my knights on the
first game i
was like oh [__]
and then there was this other moment
where he had the he had the position to
take my queen
and i just said a prayer and i was like
please god don't notice
and when he did it i was like praise
jesus there it was a good good good good
day
yeah i mean i i said this before the
game started
i mean i felt like this was going to be
the blunder fest of 2021
and uh for the first round that's
exactly what it was it was a absolute
clown fiesta
and adolescent kissy don't sell yourself
short okay there were throws in the game
by you and i both but no one will ever
be able to throw as hard as choke dog va
okay we're still not at the level of him
maybe one day in a couple years we'll be
on his level but
connor's the number one joker in north
america now well i'm trying to i'm just
trying
to be mr brady over here so you know of
course
of course but yeah i mean the first game
it was it was incredibly stressful
because in my mind i was like okay so
what i did was i didn't play any online
chess last week
i actually ordered a real chess set to
play in real life
and i played against myself or my wife
in real life but hopefully if the
feeling of the chess pieces in my hand
would hopefully ground me a little bit
more and then i goofed around with
different strategies like that
and that's what i did this week and when
the first game happened and i completely
blunted those two pieces i was like
that was the entirely wrong play to make
i should have played online
uh thankfully by some miracle of god i
got my act together for once and made a
comeback i think it was
uh when the queen was blundered which
was holy [__] thank god
uh but then round two i felt like i got
my act together i think i played a much
more solid game of chess
felt a lot more fluid um i stopped
messing around i got my head out of my
ass and uh i feel like game two was
great for me
and uh kizzy i want to say that was so
[__] fun to play against you dude oh
yeah definitely i i definitely had a
great time
just like i said it was i had a great
time playing even though
like you know my building was crashing
you know the towers were falling you
know
thanos was snapping my minions uh away
you know it was still
fun that's still like i still had a
great time
so uh yeah good stuff man uh good luck
good luck
good luck uh in the next next round but
i'm gonna have to be rooted for e sound
so okay listen listen hold on here's the
thing
here's the thing about a sam [__]
interject yes so
in my mind in my mind i'm completely out
against sam he's a god of chess he's 2
000 rating and tactics
but here's the thing oh yeah he's sam
yeah he is he's crazy high rating east
sam
is widely known as the pikachu man okay
he's electric type
but me myself i'm a proud representative
of the hippo strat aka
hip bowed on from pokemon the ground
type the hard counter
so if there's any way i have a chance to
take down one of these behemoths of the
chest field
there might be a shot for me there might
be a shot
all right see that that was a great way
to put it wow
dizzy see i was expecting more of the
like
if somebody's gonna win this whole thing
i wanted to be the guy i lost to but
you're going now you're going the other
way
oh no bro that's my teammate right there
bro it
changes the world changes now i respect
that kissy
hey and say hey if you want to beat me i
would have been the same way i want
ollie to win so bad
i'm leaving her i believe in my girl
well kizzy listen yeah i guess
now you're saying i had a great time and
again like you know
thank you so much for like just running
this tournament r2
all right i i really think this event is
like super super sick
and like now like you know you guys got
me into it you know shout outs to you
know
japanese tutor you know shout outs to
you uh
aaron i appreciate it you know everybody
you guys and
god like man like for real uh it's it's
just amazing this is an amazing thing
so and the fact that you guys are
putting so much effort behind it
uh of a very very some like you know
simple straightforward game of chess is
good i like you know
and uh yeah dude this isn't me so
hopefully when you guys do a part three
i have my redemption on
you probably might see my eyes glowing
red you know coming back with vengeance
you know they're going to talk about
they're going to call me evil
and then if i get sent to the loser i'm
going to be evil er kizzy you know we're
going to be
the eyes going to go even more red you
know
but anyways man uh thanks so much i
don't want to hold up everybody's time
but thank you so much
feels good yeah i just thought one thing
to both of you guys
um to techy first um
it looked in the first match like you
were
like you lost it but then i didn't know
if you were gonna stick with the hippo
or not
and then you did and it made me really
happy that you stopped at the opening
choice
because i was like oh no he lost twice
at the hippo like is he gonna like
like deny the the strat and then you did
it and it came through
like i was really happy about that so
yeah
no honestly thank you so much for that
like that that made me really happy
you are the only reason why i ever had a
chance in this tournament without you
i am nothing i would not disgrace your
strategy
uh in this tournament and in video games
and mmos league of legends anything i
pick
one character and i play them till the
end of time i will never break from the
hippo i don't care if my opponents know
what i'm gonna be playing next
next round i don't care i'm bringing
hippo to the goddamn finales or i'm
gonna die trying
wow well thank you for that and of
course
um i'll be seeing you in your stream i
know i'll be
in there we'll be running we'll be
running the lessons i know i'll be there
bro i promise
yep yep i i do you know lessons and
please come through
and also we have guilty gear to run
oh yeah well for me you're you're the
throne of my master right so i'm i'm
gonna see if i can just like
you guys let's see this strolling
huh okay all right man well you already
know where to meet me at man you know
i'm on i'm on i'm on the twitch ass you
know
fourth street you know
all right guys kizzy it has been
fantastic having you and unfortunately
we do
part ways here but we're happy to hear
that you've caught the chess bug
we definitely would love to see you back
in another event
and uh techtone we want to wish you good
luck in your next match and guys
get some rest and uh and we'll see you
soon
sounds good thanks for having me
and there you have it uh kizzy
put up an amazing fight in tournament
arc 2 and uh
again we of course would love to see him
back tectone
will move forward and face e sam
uh almost certain he's gonna bring the
hippo this time
jt uh you're pretty confident about that
too huh
listen i i really like the hippo it's a
strat that i employ sometimes in blitz
and
even in some classical games that i've
played i was like let me just play
the hippos what's up and i have done
very well actually i've won all of my
games at the hippo so maybe she played
more
made famous and confirmed dude right
here on tournament two uh
okay so we have our next set of matches
that we know we will be seeing
tech tone versus esam sea dog va versus
ali
and then to follow after all of that
rustage v
gigek to seal somebody's place
in the grand final on sunday uh but
until then folks
make sure that you're keeping an eye out
on chess.com social media channels
in order to know everything that's
happening and coming up in the next few
days including the schedule and
jt today has been another
another what we're used to seeing like
every single day of tournament r2 just
insane chess
uh lots of fun from the players and from
the audience and um
wow dude it's of course i i also want to
say just randomly out of nowhere it's a
pleasure
calling these matches with you and um
yeah dude like this is can you have
asked for any better so far than this
honestly like this has just been the
best and to think that we have another
three days of this
like what what is this like this this
has been so hype
whenever i see like chess commentary i'm
like okay this is so good the chess is
so good
but here we get chess we get drama we
had action
you know our hearts are racing you know
because we have our favorites and then
you know what happens if they blunder
then we blunder you know
it just brings everything together and
i'm really excited to be
i'm really happy to be part of this
event and i'm really excited for the
next couple of days
uh they're gonna be amazing and i i
thank you so much for inviting me back
and also
uh it's a pleasure commentating with you
as well
all right guys uh with that said we will
be back here tomorrow at 5 p.m pacific
with more matches more action chess.coms
tournament arc 2
will return uh tomorrow so we'll see you
all then thank you so much for being
here
and have a good night yep and i'll see
you at the after party take care guys
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
hey
you